STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Welcome, everyone.
It's good to have you here.
I see some familiar faces
and some less familiar faces.
So that's fantastic.
So what I wanted to
do is prepare to talk.
And within the talk,
I have some images,
a few videos to look
at, and there's also
a audience
participation component,
because that's just how I roll.
We have to practice
what we're up to.
So this segment, this talk, is
one that is looking at pedagogy
as not simply pedagogical
strategies in general
but to look more at the
ways that I translate
this idea of pedagogy through
lenses or filters of disruption
or of criticality.
And so part of the work
that I do professionally
is prepare teachers
of art for K12.
But I also work with
graduate students
as they conduct their
research, I also
do my own research
in scholarly kinds
of moves about the ways in which
visual imagery, visual art,
visual cultural production,
functions, as modes or spaces
for teaching and learning.
Jasper Johns, a
pop artist, someone
who's been relegated
into that space
by some critics and
historians, this
is something--
this is a statement
he made about his art practice.
Like, how do you make your art?
What's your approach?
Take an objective,
do something to it,
and I do something else to it.
Really?
Well, yeah, I mean, that
seems really simplified.
But for me, that's a really
interesting and quite powerful
methodology or method to use.
You take something, and then
that thing is not just--
it's not finished.
It's not done being
whatever it could be.
And then, do something to it.
OK, but then, keep it going.
Do something else do it.
So for me, the doing can
happen in a number of ways.
You can alter it, you can
modify it, you can throw it.
You can add something to it.
You can take something away.
But we can also, as
viewers or people
who are engaging with that
object, we might ask questions.
So the asking questions
is a form of doing.
And so for me, Johns's
quotation is nice, for me,
as a bridge from a more
modernist mindset or approach
where it's about
the object and it's
about the making, the
process of making to--
some books might
talk about the slide
into postmodernism
or other post spaces,
where we move beyond
objectness or materialness
to other realms that have
more conceptual content
and interest.
That notion of asking
questions or take an object,
doing something to it,
doing something else to it,
you could engage
learners like that.
That's one way to
engage learners.
So if we think
about learners, we
should also think
about curriculum.
Now, this is an image--
this is not one that
I drew, but it's
a cartoon, a single cartoon
panel from Non Sequitur.
And I use this image when
I teach curriculum classes.
So on the right, we
have this larger fish
with kind of sharp teeth, and
there's stuff falling down
from the fish's mouth, and then
there are these three smaller
fish, and then there's
another fish that's
kind of medium sized, and that
one actually knows how to talk,
which I think is an
interesting thing.
So we're able to
know what fish say.
The medium-sized fish says,
"No, we can't swim any faster.
The school curriculum is
geared for the slower swimmers.
So the 10 of you have to wait
for the others to catch up."
I don't know about you, I
only see four other fish.
I only see four other fish.
I do see one fish.
It looks like little fish
bits that are falling
from this larger fish's mouth.
So where is the curriculum?
Here, is the curriculum
this larger fish
with the sharp teeth?
Is the curriculum the swimming?
Is the curriculum
the water itself?
This cartoon allows us to have
multiple entry points to ask
where the curriculum resides.
And if we think about
that word "curriculum,"
it is derived from a Latin
word, currere. and that's
the infinitive "to run" So
"curriculum" is "to run."
It's the running of a
course, rather than a noun.
We think about it in
those terms, right?
Curriculum theorists did
work in the '70s and '80s
to reconceptualize
curriculum, but didn't
focus on this idea of
curriculum as a verb "to run."
So the running or, in this
case, the swimming of the course
is the curriculum--
so how they swim.
I'm assuming the medium-sized
fish is the teacher
and could be, could also
be the school principal
or whoever is in charge there.
But the middle
three are probably--
or this is supposed to
be maybe the students who
seem to know how to
swim the course the way
that it was designed.
Well, this could be
one of the learners,
too, swimming adequately.
But sometimes when I have used
this image with my students
in curriculum courses, they
talk about how this larger fish,
they often call
it the barracuda--
see, that's the curriculum.
The curriculum eats
up the swimmers
who don't swim in
predetermined ways.
Oh, OK, so here, a
curriculum is a noun
and an adversarial thing.
How depressing is that to
be a teacher or a learner
to think the curriculum's
after you; you better stay
in front of it?
But if we think
of the curriculum
as a verb in the ways
in which we swim,
maybe some swimmers swim higher
in the water, some swim lower,
some swim sideways, some
swim faster and slower.
How might the curriculum
allow for multiple swimmers
rather than a predetermined
and singular notion
of what a learner could be.
But that's if we privilege
the idea of learning.
If we think about teaching,
we can just deliver.
I mean, there are notions
of teaching and curriculum
that, from the early 1900s and
late 1800s that would proclaim
that learners are empty
vessels, and the teacher
has all the knowledge.
We just fill you
up with knowledge.
And that says, well,
you're a learner.
You don't bring anything
to the classroom.
But that's not the case.
You swim the way you swim.
Bring that to the classroom.
So this idea of shifting from
teaching to learning privileges
or allows more attention to what
learners bring to those spaces.
Well, another
standardized approach
that was very popular
100 years ago and still
somehow is popular within
some circles in art teaching
and education are
the elements of art
and the principles of design.
Some people call them the
elements and principles.
But it's the elements of art
and principles of design.
And certainly, these
are ways to say, look,
these are the things that are
going on in visual imagery
or material culture.
But they weren't intended
to be the limitations.
They were intended to be
ways to gain access to what
we're seeing in front of us.
Misinterpretation of
that, quite often,
studio teachers, art
teachers, other folks
will think that
these are the limits.
And if we only talk about line,
shape, color, texture, pattern,
rhythm, then we've
covered the curriculum.
We've taught what
we need to teach.
Well, that's an
interesting approach
if you want to avoid
content, if you
want to avoid
concepts, and ideas,
and social issues--
if you want to avoid
lived experiences in the
lives of other people.
And certainly when you're
looking at works of art that
are representative or
reflections of lived
experiences to omit interest in
what we're seeing and what is
being represented by simply
limiting it to a formalist--
and this is formalized notions--
then, we're missing part
of the conversation.
So a number of years
ago, Olivia Gude,
who is a scholar at School of
the Art Institute in Chicago.
She said, look, we're not
in this modernist notion,
and there are
different ways that we
can mobilize art practices.
And she constructed this
set of postmodern principles
by looking at the work
that her students were
making during weekend art
classes in the Spiral Workshop.
And she said, you know,
there's other principles,
the elements of art and
principles of design,
those seven--
group of seven elements and
group of seven principles
were guiding and have done
some work in art curriculum.
But she said, as I look at the
work my students are making
based on the
assignments that we're
up to in the Spiral curriculum,
that are focused on themes,
focused on social issues,
focused on concepts,
focused on lived experiences,
she said of all of these works,
these seven principles
seem to emerge,
not that the elements of
art and principles of design
aren't there.
Because I kind of dare you to
point to something in the world
that you can't talk
about in terms of line,
or shape, or texture, right?
So she's saying
that from looking
at the students' work generated
from a thematic approach
about concepts and lived
experiences in the world--
text and image is a
postmodern principle.
Hybridity, this idea of things
kind of overlapping and merging
together, gazing, the
way in which one looks,
and the perspective
from which one looks,
and how one is looked at.
Representing-- not just
to represent something
but how one's identity
gets represented
or how one represents oneself.
Appropriation-- borrowing
from one context or another;
juxtaposition, the
critique of two objects
or two images in
relationship to each other.
Recontextualization,
similar to appropriation,
but taking something
out of one context,
putting it in a
new context, now it
speaks differently about
this other context.
And layering, this idea of
how narratives or layers can
be read through each other
for multiple meanings.
And I love what she
says, which is also
the pull-out quotation
from this article,
"An infinite amount of time is
wasted in misdirected effort
because tradition
has a strong hold."
I mean, there are other
things that we can be doing,
but, because we're
regimented in tradition,
we just can't get there.
All right, so let's engage
some learners like this.
How about being some learners?
Good?
All right, I have--
we have large paper.
These are essentially
jumbo-sized Post-it notes.
And we have markers.
We have markers of
different colors.
Most of them are
also gigantic sizes.
It's like this larger cartoon
version of Post-it notes
and little markers.
And what I would
like you to do is,
we're going to use this approach
where we're going to do--
it's derived from
think, pair, share--
this approach of
learning, where I
want you to think on
your own, and then you're
going to find someone else to
pair with, and connect with,
and then you're going to share
your ideas with each other,
then we'll share with the group.
So what I'd like
you to do right now
is, if you have something to
write with, that's great--
I don't think we brought
any normal-sized paper,
but I'll give you two
minutes to do this first part
to think on your own.
What I would like you
to do is choose one--
I'm not going to
decide for you, but I'd
like you to choose on your
own, one of these tasks,
one of these
statements, and I want
you to come up with a list.
So if you choose the
first one, you're
going to come up with a
list of 10 important women
in the history of the world.
Don't show anybody.
Keep it to yourself for now.
Or you could choose
the second one.
You can make a list
of 10 important events
in the history of the world.
Or you can make a list of
10 important human creations
in the history of the world.
Does that make sense?
Two minutes, go for it, and
then we'll come back together.
The activity that
we are doing is one
that I use in a curriculum
development class and also
curriculum theory class,
usually near the beginning
of the semester to underscore
this idea that curriculum
development, curriculum
design, curriculum,
as a general practice,
is a political act,
and it's based in values.
It's based in experiences.
Imagine a textbook company
approached you and says,
oh, you could get this contract
for a textbook, a history book.
We only have enough
money for 10 chapters.
So if you had 10 weeks to
teach a course, what 10 topics
would you teach?
You've got to decide
what doesn't get taught.
Deciding what is not
in the curriculum
is part of the political act.
It's part of the
decision-making.
So these three prompts
are ones that I've
used for years, and
years, and years
to do exactly what we did.
You did it in like 15 minutes.
I typically spend 15 minutes
having the students generate
the ideas, then we
spend 45 minutes
critiquing and interpreting.
We're not going to spend
45 minutes critiquing
and interpreting, but I'll lead
you through some of the things
that I like to do.
Which prompt was this one?
AUDIENCE: It's events?
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
This is events?
This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Creations.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Creations?
What was this one?
AUDIENCE: Creations.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Creations.
AUDIENCE: Women.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Women.
AUDIENCE: Creations.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Creations.
Now, notice the
prompts are-- we'll
talk about how I worded the
prompts in a little bit.
I find it interesting-- this
is just the way I'm reading
your lists--
one, two, three, four of
the five lists use numbers.
My assumption is that the one
entry next to the number one
is the most important,
only because it's listed--
I'm just kind of culturally--
you know in that habit.
When I see a one, I think
of that being first.
Usually, first is most important
unless you're David Letterman;
you're reading your
top-10 lists backwards.
If you had a last-minute email
from the publisher, [GASP]
we just got some more money.
We could add another
chapter to your textbook.
But you've got to tell us by the
end of the business day today.
Could you come up
with your number 11?
Right?
Or, oh, I'm sorry.
Our budget has been slashed.
We have to cut two chapters.
Which two are the
least important.
These are questions that
curriculum designers,
curriculum developers
make all the time.
Teachers, how much
time do we have
in the semester or the
school year to teach?
Oh, we only got so far.
We've got to hurry up and rush
because this is more important.
And somebody else told
us this was important,
so we've got to teach--
well, I'm not teaching that.
That seems less important.
These are political decisions.
But what is in is only there
because it wasn't left out.
A critical pedagogy
or pedagogy that I
like to enact and encourage
my students to use
is one that asks these
kinds of questions.
It's constantly in
this frame of asking.
Even when we have our list, even
when we have our decision of,
what seems to be important--
well, why is this on the list?
And where else does
this allow us to go?
If we take Toni Morrison,
what can we do with her work?
Where does her work allow us
to go, following Jasper Johns?
And then, where does
that allow us to go?
Take Toni Morrison,
not an object--
but we can think
it in those ways--
take this entry, do something
to it, do something else to it.
The word "most" doesn't appear
in any of those prompts.
Did you pick up on that?
Why do you think I didn't
put the word "most" in there?
AUDIENCE: Too much pressure.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Too much pressure?
On me?
I could've easily written--
I'm fine with four-letter words.
I can just-- so, too
much pressure for whom?
AUDIENCE: For us,
for [INAUDIBLE]
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Even though I think
we still tried to do that,
it didn't feel--
it felt, like, OK, what
are 10 important events you
can come up with.
AUDIENCE: And it's subjective.
What's most important
to me is probably not
what's most important to you, or
her, or whoever's sitting here.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: OK.
AUDIENCE: "Most" might have
got in the way of the word
"important."
Because if you don't have
the "most" there, you think,
what is important,
and [INAUDIBLE]
STEPHEN CARPENTER: So it's
kind of a pedagogical strategy
to take some stress
away, to allow entry,
to remove some of the
complications embedded
in just working out the
different values ahead of time
anyway.
I mean, certainly, those
are important conversations.
Not the stress.
I don't like to induce
stress in students.
But to make an activity
or allow an activity
to have points of
entry for people
where they feel like they can
be part of that work is crucial.
AUDIENCE: I also think that
now, that all the lists are
done, that because the
word "most" is not there,
it's not a final list.
So I can look at
somebody else's list
and say, OK, that is
also important, as
opposed to a final list
of the most important.
So it allows for changing
after it's done up there.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Absolutely.
So it's not fixed.
Absolutely.
But that notion of curriculum,
for a lot of people--
it's fixed.
It's done.
It's a noun.
It's not a running.
It's not a continuation.
It's not a springboard
and a prompt.
You're exactly right.
It's a point of
continuous learning.
Yeah, good stuff.
All right, so let's
slide back up here.
Wow, this is about 20 years ago.
And I was working with
hypertext software, story space.
So you kind of see that
map in the upper left.
And my idea was, I go
to the barber shop,
and I get my haircut.
But I learn a lot of
stuff in that barber shop.
I think this barber shop
might be a curriculum.
It might be an
educational space.
No, it's a hypertext.
There's a bunch of moving parts
and different relation-- maybe
it's all of those things.
So I started to overlap those
different thoughts into a piece
called "Pat's Barbershop."
One day I asked the gathering
of barbers and clients,
what can someone learn in here?
Meaning, what can someone
learn in this barber shop?
And this barber shop is
in Norfolk, Virginia,
predominately African-American
segment of Norfolk.
This was when I was on faculty
at Old Dominion University.
So I asked Pat, the
owner and lead barber,
what can somebody learn in here?
And according to
Pat, people learn
a lot about life,
education, business,
the street, the whole nine.
Someone else noted with a smirk,
they learn what a gram is.
He was talking about
illicit substances.
How much you can get
for a stolen TV--
"and they can learn
that crack is good.
We love crackheads."
What he meant was--
the first part he was
actually being sarcastic.
But the second part, he
was being more supportive.
In a matter-of-fact
tone, one of the barbers
commented, If you could put
a camera in here for a week,
you could make a movie.
At one point, Pat himself
responded to my question
in a melodic chant, "OJ did it!
OJ did it!--" a reference to a
scene in the movie Barbershop
and the famous court trial.
Later, in a more serious
tone, Pat proudly
stated, "Younger
teenagers, learn from me.
Don't sell drugs, be successful,
keep a straight head."
Pat admitted that, in his place,
you learn about everyday life.
And this project
went on for years.
And they'd call me "Professor"--
"Hey, Professor, guess what?"
And they would start to tell
me what they learned recently
until I'd get new lessons.
And so this article is
filled with different ways
to think about that
barbershop as a hypertext.
Looking at other
subsequent work, not only
am I artist in residence
here at MIT this year,
but I'm also an
artist in residence
at a local elementary
school back where I live.
I've been working with first
graders and third graders.
So you know what I
did a few weeks ago?
I talked to third graders
about epidemiology,
which is what you do, right?
I showed them this map.
My intention wasn't
to talk specifically
about epidemiology.
My intention was
to talk about how
the visual
representation of ideas
or how the visual
representation of data
and the visual
representation of information
might allow us access to ways
of knowing and understanding
that we wouldn't have without
those visual representations.
So here, we have a
segment of London.
And you see a bunch
of dots there.
And those dots,
essentially, are the places
where John Snow,
in the late 1800s,
identified people who
had died from cholera.
And his theory, which was
different than local theory
and the common theory
at that point--
his theory was, people were
getting cholera from water.
Everybody else, said, no!
It's in the air.
Or, it's divine intervention.
Or, something else is going on.
John, you don't know what
you're talking about.
So I told the kids this.
I didn't tell them this yet.
I said, here's a map.
What do you see?
Oh, it's a map.
OK.
And what else do you see?
Well, I see a bunch of dots.
What do you think
those dots are?
Those are the people.
That's where they live.
Or, maybe that's where
something happened.
Why are there more dots
here and not over there?
I don't know.
And they said, oh,
wait, there's some X's.
What do you think those X's are?
And they had all these ideas.
Well, you don't see the X's?
Here are the X's.
The X's are here.
Oh, OK, that's helpful.
Thanks.
So what's going on?
Tell me about the relationship
between the X's and the dots.
Oh, well, most of the dots are
in the middle, and most of them
are on that green
dot in the center.
I said, oh, you know what?
That's what John
Snow thought, too.
Guess what he figured out?
That's where the people
were getting sick.
were dying, because they
were drinking the water.
And it was because he was able
to visually represent the data,
he could get to
this observation.
They thought that
was pretty cool.
Then, I told them,
so now, here's
a new word-- epidemiology.
A bunch of eight
and nine-year-olds
saying, "epidemiology."
It was great.
But they start to understand
how visual representation
of information allows access
to ideas in different ways.
And I said, if you like this
map, what about this one?
Other people thought that
that map was interesting, too.
How many different
ways could you
represent data
visually using a map?
Other people thought John
Snow's idea was really cool.
Oh, and then as soon
as I showed this, oh!
That's Google Maps!
Eight and nine-year-olds
know about Google Maps?
Yeah.
Hmm.
So now, how does
Google Maps play
into how we might teach
in elementary school
about space, about
visual representation?
Just taking an object,
and doing something to it,
and doing something else to it?
I do something similar with
my preservice teachers.
As they're preparing
to become teachers
and preparing to go out into
classrooms to do their student
teaching, when
they're just trying
to figure out how
learning and teaching
happens in educational
spaces, one
of the tasks I give
them is, all right,
go ahead and do your
next observation.
What I want you to do
is, when you sit down,
I want you to draw a map of the
classroom on a piece of paper
and take with you
a marker that you
know will bleed if you leave it
too long on the piece of paper.
And what I want
you to do is I want
you to make a note of
where all of the furniture
is in the room--
entry points, exit points--
I want you to indicate where
the students are when you enter
the room and indicate
where the teacher is
by putting your marker down.
And the entire time
that you're there,
you move your marker
wherever the teacher moves.
And when the teacher stops,
you stop your marker.
When the teacher starts
moving, you move the marker.
So if the teacher
stops, the marker stops.
If the marker stops, the
marker starts to bleed.
It starts to, over time,
take up more and more space.
And then, I collect these
maps, and we look at them.
We start talking about the
relationship between where
the teacher is in
the room, where
the learners are in the room,
how the content is conveyed.
We talk about, what were
the kids doing over here?
If they're sitting over here,
what were the kids doing?
Because it looks
like the teacher
was over here most of the time.
Were they talking?
Were they engaged?
Were they moving
around the room?
I'll show you some other maps.
This person didn't use a marker,
so they just kind of kept
scribbling and overlapping.
This is curious, isn't it?
This teacher is either
exhausted, or on Rollerblades,
or something.
The teacher's all over the
place, maybe not in a bad way.
Certainly, not giving a lecture
like I'm doing right now.
How do you know?
Well, look at the map!
Well, where was the teacher?
The teacher was,
essentially, everywhere,
interacting with
different students,
moving to one station,
moving to another station.
The teacher filled
that space physically.
So in the conversations
that would
have to be generated
later would be,
so then, what was happening
among the learners, too?
What relationship does
this teacher movement
have to do with the ways in
which students are learning?
Whoa, look at that teacher!
What might we learn about
the practice of teaching
and the practice of learning
by visualizing movement?
You could try to do it
with all the students,
but I don't know if
you have enough fingers
to move all the
kids around, right?
Interpretation--
the construction
of meaning or the attending to
the construction of meanings
by talking about and making
sense of works of art.
Ooh, do you know about America
Rock and Schoolhouse Rock?
When I was a kid, these shows
would come on Saturday morning
cartoons between the cartoon--
two or three-minute
videos, Schoolhouse Rock
and America Rock.
America Rock was a
way for us to learn
about the history of
the United States--
or "a" history of
the United States.
So here, you see some
of the episodes--
"No More Kings," "The
Founding of America,"
"Fireworks," "The
Declaration of Independence,"
"The Preamble of
the Constitution."
I know the entire
preamble because I
watched Schoolhouse Rock--
"We, the people, in order to
form a more perfect union--"
The one at the top is
from "No More Kings."
There's King George
in the middle.
[GIGGLE]
Ooh, Boston Tea Party.
Is that big cup still
here in the water?
No?
The one on the bottom--
this is called "Elbow Room"--
elbow room, elbow room, got to
got to get me some elbow room.
That's where I learned the
word "manifest destiny"--
or the term "manifest destiny."
Schoolhouse Rock.
This is the melting pot, shaped
in the form of the Continental
United States--
little guy just jumps right in.
"It doesn't matter
what your skin.
Those are the lyrics."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - SCHOOLHOUSE ROCK, "NO
MORE KINGS"]
(SINGING) Rockin' and a-rollin,
splishin' and a-splashin,
over the horizon,
what can it be?
The pilgrins sailed
the sea to find a place
to call their own in
their ship Mayflower.
They hoped to find
a better home.
They finally knocked
on Plymouth Rock
and someone said, "We're there."
It may not look like home, but
at this point, I don't care.
Oh, they were missing
Mother England.
They swore their loyalty
until the very end.
Anything you say, King.
It's OK, King.
You know, it's kind
of scary on your own.
build a new land
the way we planned.
Could you help us run
it until it's grown?
They planted corn, you know.
They built their
houses one by one.
And bit by bit, they worked
until the colonies were done.
They looked around, yeah, up and
down, and someone said, Hurray!
If the king could only see us
now, he would be proud of us
today!
They knew that now they'd
run their own land.
But George III still vowed
he'd rule until the end.
Anything I say,
do it my way now.
Anything I say, do it my way.
Don't you get to feeling
independent because I'm
going to force you to obey!
He taxed their property.
He didn't give them any choice.
And back in England, he
didn't give them any voice.
That's called taxation
without representation,
and it's not fair.
But when the colonies
complained, the king said,
I don't care.
He even has the nerve
to tax our cup of tea.
To put it kindly, King,
we really don't agree.
Going to show you how we feel.
We're going to this tea
and turn this harbor
into the biggest cup
of tea in history!
They wanted no more
Mother England.
They knew the time had come
for them to take command.
It's very clear
you're being unfair,
King, no matter what
you say, we won't obey.
Going to hold a
revolution now, King,
and we're gonna
run it all our way.
With no more kings--
We're going to
elect a president.
No more kings.
He's going to do
what the people want.
No more kings.
We're going to run
things our way!
No more kings!
Nobody's going to
tell us what to do!
Rockin' and a-rollin',
splishin' and a-splashin'.
Over the horizon,
what can it be?
Looks like it's going
to be a free country.
[CHEERS]
[END OF VIDEO PLAYBACK]
STEPHEN CARPENTER: What
a great place to live.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, the president
does what the people want.
Like, what else did
you learn from that?
I just learned
that the president
does what the people want.
What else did you learn
about this country
based from this
Schoolhouse Rock video?
AUDIENCE: That we stand
up for what we want?
OK.
Fight for what we want.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: OK,
fight for what we want,
stand up for what we want.
What else did you learn?
Pilgrims and the colonists
didn't pay any attention
to people living there.
Were there people living
here in this video?
AUDIENCE: There were these--
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
There were three.
AUDIENCE: We learned about
what we didn't learn.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Oh, what
we didn't-- tell me something.
AUDIENCE: All the
things that we didn't
learn that this video wildly
misrepresented and erased
a crucial part of
history before and after.
And even in the
implications of "freedom,"
it was freedom for white males.
But it paints a very
nice, easy picture
of what history was
that is not true,
and it has repercussions now
because of a false history.
STEPHEN CARPENTER
: Well, I mean,
they only had three minutes.
I mean, you only had 10 slots.
If you had 11 slots, that--
they only had three minutes.
How can they put
all that stuff in--
I'm being, you know.
So if you're an art teacher,
let's say you're assigned to
or you're teaching
interdisciplinary unit,
working with the
history teacher,
you could justify
showing this video--
I mean, illustration,
video production
can be taught through
the art classroom.
The history teacher
can pull the--
there's history being taught.
I could justify following a
prescribed curriculum that
says, history teacher
and art teacher
will work collaboratively
to teach together.
Yeah, OK, we're watching
some Schoolhouse Rock,
and we're going to
interpret through--
remember those
pedagogical lenses that--
well, you were applying many
of them in your reading.
And we were applying
many of them
in our reading of that list.
So as an art teacher
or just a teacher who
likes to cause trouble, or
ask questions, or promote
critical thinking, we could
show these videos like this,
or you could show any
visual culture example
in interpreting critique
through those different lenses.
So I want to show you a
couple of assignments.
This assignment is by another
colleague, Andres Hernandez,
who teaches at School of the
Art Institute in Chicago.
And so this is a project
that he asked the students
to do where he uses this
quotation to talk about this
and to question this term,
"informal settlements."
Now, you think about refugees.
You think about people
who have been displaced.
And to think about
the housing that they
have constructed for themselves
is informal-- really?
It's as formal as
it's going to get
for those folks in that moment.
I mean, the terminology
itself is problematic.
And so he's thinking
about these--
if you think about
these kinds of places,
it says, in fewer words, the
city produced by the people.
So inspired by the notion of,
a city produced by people,
he tells the students who are
learning to be art teachers--
and we have these open spaces at
Vermont College of Fine Arts--
you're going to
take on this space,
and you're going to build
a shelter out of cardboard,
and it has to have-- and
there are certain criteria.
You have to have a certain
number of people in it.
And by doing that,
at the bottom,
you see the purpose
of this assignment
is that it's this
intuitive building using
limited materials and
is focused on a 1 to 1
scale or the scale of real life.
So right there, because
it's not a model,
because it's scaled
at real life,
there's a way that
our bodies enter
into the reality and maybe into
the reality of other people.
It says, "Further purposes
of this design brief
is a basic introduction
of site specificity
as well as full-scale
prototyping and sketch
modeling."
And then, at the
end, these models
can be used to design
to talk about principles
of structure, enclosure,
construction techniques.
So these are elements
I would assume
that are part of many
other disciplines,
architecture, urban
planning, and so forth.
But the idea is
that he's drawing
from a quotation from
a theoretical argument
focusing on a term and saying,
this term is problematic.
Let's see what we
might learn and how
we might trouble this term
through the act of making
works of art.
And then, those
works of art allow
us to gain literally
entry points into them,
but also entry into the
complications of what
those terms mean.
Here's another assignment
Andres provides the students.
Find a building and
engage with the spaces.
And then, document it
through photography.
So what do you learn about
the physicality of a building
by becoming part
of that building,
by becoming part of
the negative spaces?
You could write about it.
You could measure it--
tape measures.
Or, your body could
try to fit in there
and try to understand
what that space is about.
I know from teaching drawing,
one technique we can do,
if we put a chair, or
a series of chairs,
or still life in the
middle of the room,
we all had our drawing paper.
We could start
drawing what we see.
And that would get us so far.
But one strategy an art teacher
will always do or often do
is say, I want you to
draw what's not there.
I want you to draw
the negative space.
And when you draw the negative
spaces between the chair,
the spaces between the bars, and
the spaces between the handles
and the rungs--
by drawing and rendering
those negative spaces
as accurately as possible, you
render the positive spaces.
So what do we learn by
studying what is not
there or the neglected spaces?
We learn more about the presence
of the dominant structure.
So there are a number
of books about pedagogy
and about translating art
practice and pedagogical
engagements in
public spaces, right?
So I'll just conclude
here for some questions.
You know, you can engage
learners like this--
or you could do boring stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
It's up to you.
All right, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]